[Music]
[Applause]
hey everyone welcome to awesome comics
your one-stop shop for everything comic
book entertainment related I'm your host
Heather Ruth today and today we are
talking about Henry Cavill Superman is
he a good Superman is he not does he
suck hmm we'll see we'll see we have
some hot debate take a lot we're so hot
debating for you today but before we get
into that don't forget to like our
Facebook page facebook.com slash awesome
comics show we put up new contents there
every Thursday sometimes more we had a
continued discussion from our last Lego
Batman movie discussion that went up
there on Thursday it was fun
there were lots of random Legos on my
earrings and firing of LEGO pieces at
other people so check that out and
already on the panel today we have
someone new order Jake say hello hello
how you doing you excited man yeah I'm
very excited I've been a big fan for a
long time and it's cool to get into the
nitty-gritty and I'm ready to do some
classic awesome comments arguing yeah
yeah this will be a throne today maybe I
don't know baby and on the other hand we
have porter up now you know yeah been
around for a while
welcome welcome back you were off
gallivanting around Florida right yeah
Harry Potter Wizarding World Disney
World all that stuff great stuff great
stuff yeah that's good it really is a
happy place
well good I'm glad that you can spread
the joy all right so we have some three
main topics that we're going to focus on
let's just jump right into it the first
thing we're going to talk about is
probably one of the biggest issues
people have with him is the tone and the
attitude that he has yeah you know the
dark gritty nature so to speak brooding
yes really
so I like that you put that environment
brooding our quotation marks where I
teach English so let's throw it to you
first Jake oh okay so the tone attitude
how do you feel about um I don't mind it
I know that it's gotten a lot of flack
especially BBS for how dark it's gotten
and how somber he is and he doesn't seem
to really smile much which I mean I'll
grieve at that point but no it doesn't
bother me much because I don't know for
a long time we have the same Superman in
terms of our media in them and the
movies in the anime series in the 90s he
was always very much the Big Blue Boy
Scout and he very much has his rigid
moral compass and there's it gets kind
of boring when you don't really give
much dramatic tension to his
decision-making and things along that
line so I really appreciate it
especially men feel that we're getting
some shades to his character and I think
that the it's I don't think it's so much
brooding like Batman brooding as it is
that they were just kind of shading his
character I like that they made him more
of a he felt out of place in the world
because he doesn't know why he's
different
he knows he's different he doesn't know
why his parents are more afraid of
letting his his his powers out which
leads to him being a little more
reserved so I like that there's this
more of like a coming-of-age vibe to
especially like the first half a Man of
Steel as he starts to realize that I
should be able to show these these
powers and I think that and lends to him
being conflicted and complicated but not
necessarily like I don't think he's dark
and like a depressed character like
Batman could be I think he's he's feels
the way of the world on his shoulders
once he realizes that he has the power
to shake the world if he wishes
so I appreciate it um I know that a lot
of people have issues with with
especially the second half of Man of
Steel with all the destruction that he's
he's part of and that that's so anti the
classic he should be flying around
saving everybody and anti the classic
depiction of Superman to have him being
so involved in this fight that he's just
trying to survive it and not necessarily
save everybody
so I some of the shades to his character
so I the tone doesn't son
bother me I think it's it's more
interesting than just this he's always
doing good he's this beacon of hope of
open well it's not a net but I but I I
think that it's uh it lends to not
necessarily have taken great advantage
of but it lends itself to more
storytelling opportunities than if you
then you can just did something like
Superman Returns which is just a rehash
of stuff that we think of the past 40
years okay now adding a new dimension to
an old character exactly thank so many
present we could show his emote in aged
years in every single movie now it's
great right I can't wait right um I feel
like you said like having the weight of
his world on his shoulders and you know
discovering his powers and whatnot yeah
that's fine
have him grapple with his huge
responsibilities of whether or not he
needs to handle that but I feel like
it's him buckling a little under that
weight and Superman he can handle the
weight over the world literally on his
shoulders so kids are mentally I think
he should be able to handle it a little
more and I think also you know he said
always seem that a lot in this neck
that's kind of because it's the core of
a character at the heart of Superman he
is the Boy Scouts is the beacon of hope
and he always does the right thing and
there's been so many so many
descriptions and whether like situations
whether or not he is going to do the
right thing and it tested them time and
time again he always does the right
thing Superman versus the elite you know
that's a great movie that describes on
what he should and shouldn't do and we
get to see a little bit of the depth of
his character in there but he still
comes around to the to the light so to
speak and I feel like part of that from
his upgrade upbringing my own pot Kent
oh should I just let those people drown
I don't know maybe a pod can do I've
never said right right save the kid no I
feel like part of the reason why you go
broody and like kind of doesn't know
exactly what seeds out great upbringing
and this is a lot different and and I
feel yes mom and pot Kent were always
scared for their son but they knew I'm
scared but he needs to be this beacon of
hope he needs to help sharp people who
use powers and I feel like that's very
lacking in Manas field and it just
transfers to his character he just kind
of like doesn't know where he fits in
the should I or shouldn't I it it always
should be yes I should because I've got
these powers and it's my responsibility
sure
and he just this brooding emo I don't
know what I should do I'm whiny blah
blah blah it's just like this doesn't
fit this character at all like we show
depth of character and show him
grappling with stuff but at the end of
it have him should bring forth the light
that he always like he doesn't seem like
he's you know very sure of himself so
and I feel like him flying around you
know not saving people in this Matt
doing the battle like I it's like okay
yeah he's new like in earth one he had
some trouble with like what he was doing
and saving people are not stuff to but
he should released made an attempt but
he really didn't it was just building
smash building smash firing through a
building tossing that's doing that bad
guy bad guy punch punch okay I'm gonna
go save that random person not really
though like he just didn't really try to
save anybody I think he might have
mentioned oh we should probably get this
out of the city but now we wound up back
in the city just cold rising sharing
yeah so I just felt like so he doesn't
ignore the character didn't feel like he
cared well he did not care about it as
much and that's ridiculous for Superman
okay well yeah some of the I land feel
is such a compressed timeline of a movie
in terms of from when he gets on the
ship and he gets the costume to the
fight of Zod has got to be a matter of
two days maybe three days so it's the
first time that he's worn this costume
in this symbol so the first time that
he's fought anything that could actually
put up a fight with him but it's not the
first time you saved people know he grew
up savings yeah saving kids in the bus
he saved the oil tanker or the oil drill
people or whatever he did oh yeah yeah
yeah like he knows he needs to use his
powers to save people and yes you're
trying to save them by euro not making
sure the world doesn't blow up and we
appreciate that but also try not to drop
a building on a bunch of people sure I
mean I don't word it perfect we've had
the only crazy super-powered person in
that fight I think that there's a lot of
collateral damage but it's a lot of he's
trying to survive
second a second against an enemy he
doesn't think he can defeat and it's the
key you know he's caught up in the
moment and more of like a fight or
flight and yeah you gotta keep fighting
because he needs to stay alive and if
you had two people with the power of
Superman fighting each other in the
middle of the downtown city you're going
to have some fake fall down yeah but I
don't think that he's like email in the
beginning I think that he's pretty much
normal teenager who feels like he
doesn't fit in like most to do except
that he has these superpowers so it's an
extra layer on top of it I don't think
he's acceptable emo I think he's uh more
towards the the middle one he's actually
an adult sure I like the idea of that he
seems to have been traveling the world
like he's really helping out people kind
of getting the hang of what he can do
and I think math feel especially is more
of the beginning of him becoming the
Superman that we know and love I feel
like he
what makes Superman relatable when the
storytelling is done well is that he a
lot of people like to write him or
portray him as this like alien on earth
that he's separated from everybody's
above everybody he feels this distance
and I like when there's a dichotomy
between that and the fact that he's a
normal American kid that grew up on a
farm and even wet right yeah so he's
normal earthling human being who finds
out that even alien and has these powers
and I like that Man of Steel seems to do
a better job of saying like this is a
guy who grew up here who now has to deal
with all of this as opposed to just this
godly Savior from above you know space
Jesus all right well this is what are
you yeah
so everyone knows that Superman is not
just the only person who's part of the
character we also have Clark Kent
sure hardest character um so how do you
feel about Aaron cabals portrayal of
Clark Kent
let's throat supporter verse well for
the ten minutes that we saw Clark Kent
is probably not bad I mean it's still a
little kind of like that it sucks
couldn't kill even Milliken but uh you
know we barely got to see any we didn't
see any of like Clark Kent as we know
him in Man of Steel until be very end
that was the tag of the frickin movie so
hi I'm Clark Kent
cut oh okay we don't get anything okay
cool
and then oh man of steel well those
three hour movies though they are cut
out for a Batman mr. brannis three hour
movie you know three and a half hour cut
you actually show a little bit of more
of Clark Kent actually being a reporter
instead of just going
I don't like Batman right and that's it
it's basically what his involvement was
in the regular theatrical cut and he we
barely saw any bit of him and but what
we did see wasn't terrible but it was it
just wasn't wasn't really the bumbling
fumbling lovable fool or anything that
we know and love it was just kind of
like a guy that had glasses and it might
be a reporter sometimes which I actually
appreciate it I think it was a little
more realistic to have him not be such
like an over the top like bumbling nerd
and that he's just like a normal guy
your office because you're not going to
suspect the whole thing is you're not
going to suspect that a normal guy in
office would ever be Superman because
why would Superman ever work in a
newspaper when he could just fly around
the world all day you know why would he
ever live a normal life you're not
expecting to have a secret identity
so the fact thing is more of just kind
of like a normal guy and everything
works better because it gets a little a
little too much when it's like look at
this bumbling nerds this guy could never
be Superman you know it's like well
nobody could be Superman you shouldn't
expect anybody around you to be Superman
not just the nerd guy because he's too
he's too nerdy to pull it off you know
so I appreciated that it was more
toned-down and that he was just kind of
a regular guy it wasn't so different
from who he is a Superman to make it
feel like he's always constantly acting
which I think can get a little old when
it
at least constantly doing the stick of
like well what you know so I appreciate
that it wasn't as although like I agree
with you actually that like we don't get
enough of it so far and part of that is
that Man of Steel it was the first movie
of this extended universe and Man of
Steel Man of Steel keep both doing the
basics my college both movies man feel
and Batman Samantha's it's still the
beginning of this they're still I'm
hoping once Superman Returns spoiler
alert Superman's gonna return and
Justice League guys he's not dead my god
doesn't say that guys when Superman
comes back that he's going to be much
closer to our classic version of
Superman because of the things that have
happened to him already could be that
he's going to come back and be a
brighter maybe a smile guys you might be
a brighter character I just feel like um
you'll be you know not as bumbling a
whatever it feels like he's too close to
Superman and so they're all out Perry's
ass about you know the Batman and we
need to do it and it's like the bad guy
and this neck is just all like yeah we
need to save it we need to like do this
this story and make sure that people
know that Batman is bad blah blah blah
because you know I'm a champion I'm good
thanks and it's like yo glasses off just
a little game no one wants to see Clark
Kent taking on the Batman by the
Superman that could be a movie there
wasn't enough of a separation from
Superman cherry okay and it feels like
if anyone obviously Lois was just like
hey aren't you super right right it's a
reporter sheet she went she went coffee
apparently a genius even more than like
like she just found you know smart like
we figured it out too though pretty
quick didn't mean not as quick as lows
not even quick of what journalists
showed about now who should show up in
his house right or at the cemetery yeah
she's like so calm down I like you yeah
I'm just like okay lying around open
fuel surprise winning journalist well
flank and figure it out I feel like we
need a little bit more of a separation
from Superman turns you know she's not
exactly brain trust up there despite the
fact that she feels her a prize-winning
you know yeah world famous alright baby
was going into
mobile hotspot with the CIA you know
maybe instead move on what the maritime
method alright so our last thing that
we're going to cut a tackle here is what
we'll call the ethics I guess a Superman
Henry Cavill Superman basically should
he have killed Zod isn't really part of
the Superman character to do something
like that we'll talk it over to Jake
first well I mean he's he's killed
people my comics before mostly not just
run-of-the-mill people usually some kind
of incredibly powerful enemy and there's
no other option and it's not like he
said I can never take a life if it's if
it's an extreme situation but none to do
it but it's specifically for Man of
Steel I think plot wise it works in the
in the scenario that's happening in
terms of Zod is going to kill this
family which I don't get why he starts
looking at them over here and then
traces his vision towards them just look
at them first and then you just play
Bradley but are you trying to kill his
family a man's got to stop that from
happening and he's seen all this
destruction happened in this fight that
he's had and the world engine is almost
good plan so he knows if if I don't stop
him he will double never stops himself
he's genetically bred to do this he
wants to save our civilization even if
he's going around going about the wrong
way but he will not stop and I think
Superman has a realization as he's in
that moment of like I have the power to
end this and I it's my responsibility to
the planet to do so and I feel
somatically it's why like at the moment
is thematically I like the idea that
he's the last Son of Krypton because of
his own actions that he has the
opportunity to bring back some semblance
of his home his planet and there's at
least someone else with that connection
so he's not alone in the world in that
moment when Zod and his forces are there
he's not alone in the world anymore he's
not alone in the universe even though
they're on the other side of him so when
he decides that he has takes adds life
and in doing so is dooming himself to
being the left on Krypton I think that's
and I think that's an interesting
storytelling thing I don't know if
perhaps they took enough advantage of
that moving forward in
I hope maybe if they move forward with
this Superman sequel that they're
talking about that George Miller's
getting rumored to do which would be
awesome that maybe they can play up damn
waters they didn't really follow up on
that much in Batman Superman but I do
like the idea that he's the last Son of
Krypton because of his own actions and I
think that's interesting
so I think that's not something that we
we get a lot another portrayal is good
man so I I don't mind it I think plot
wise he had the reasons to do it and I
think semantically it works really well
so cool semantically I mean as far as
the story goes I could see how that
would work but Superman I mean yes he
has killed in the comics but he makes it
a point to never kill as often as
possible and I feel like in that
instance so he's got Zod in this
headlock thing and break it down and God
still turning his head and he's
apparently not able to stop his head
from turning he's Superman who can fly
his powers haven't been taken away or
anything there is no red Sun jump just
jump may be sobs jumping down at that
moment I just can't see but he's like
pushing himself down yeah I kind of
doubt it so I just jump maybe no rocks
float they're falling down around it
yeah I know no no all right jump it fall
to the side I don't know punch him in
the head a few times freeze breath his
face I don't anything what do you do
after that what's the what's the
solution once even if you'd like knocked
him out where do you morning funds on to
the Phantom Zone there's a throne in
space thrown to the moon whatever
something welcome back take it a mega
prison I don't know
don't kill him you don't kill people
Superman does not kill as office I feel
like this was a situation where he
totally could have done a bunch of other
things to at least save that family and
then just figure it out as he's going
along something throw them at the
Machine thing I don't know I didn't know
the spaceships have like warp drive
capabilities thrown back on the
spaceship and warp drive it out of here
like sure something like crashed
anything resides just casually breaking
his necklace oh I got him here anyway
he's all ye screams because he's you
know sadly he's killing someone who
you know could be whatever but it's like
no you could have done so many different
things and I feel like how dark his
character is portrayed poeple can say
maybe you shouldn't have saved him
she snaps his Maki super brooding it's
like this this Superman is like nowhere
near the Superman that we've ever really
seen oh we need to be of them be more
realistic sure haven't be morally
realistic but stay true to the character
we got 75 plus years of lore of him
being this beacon of hope and not
killing as often as possible and I feel
like this situation did not warrant the
death of Zod sure and it it just didn't
work with that character and that
character is completely far off and what
we're supposed to be seeing in Superman
so kind of like the straw that broke the
camel's back for you and Kate in the
case of well this is not the Superman
that I know and love so this is Natalie
so thank you feel good any other
Superman movie you walk out I'm supposed
to feel happy in this and I just feel
like you know there was happy ending
whatever I walked out of mana feel like
what did I just see I'm going to kill
someone
what is happening like I was not at all
happy like at all now see and I was
excited because I liked that it was you
know the first three days of him being
Superman and that there's all these
things happening to him that will inform
him he's got a long road to go they're
starting this whole semi universe
there's I like that there's room for
character growth for him to become this
the the Superman we want him to be based
on what happens in the movies so far and
you know we'll see maybe maybe once he
comes back from the dead he will come
back in a black outfit with a mullet and
machine guns like in the comics but I'm
hoping not I'm hoping he comes back and
because he was forced to kill Zod and
and make himself the last survivor of
his planet and maybe that's going to
wouldn't like would you feel better if
going forward in movies they addressed
and were like because of what he did now
never will kill again yeah but I feel
like he never should have gotten to that
point I mean I feel like Superman always
starts off with the code of I'm never
going to kill it doesn't have to take a
time oh I killed someone I really didn't
like that I'm not going to do it again
you know I feel I feel like that's how
you develop a
no one really you could develop a
towards a second is like this is this is
100% how I'm living the rest of my life
I'm pretty sure not murdering someone is
something you get pretty early on like
maybe I can't you know oh I have that
entire planet from this crazy superpower
maniac that's going to kill everybody if
I don't is you know a positive right I
mean I'm sure we could sit here and
debate this all day guys but
unfortunately we got to wrap it up so
they're a good point for me thank you
very much
what do you guys think I'm actually
split that's why I'm here in the chair
doesn't cook I'm pretty well split
watching it about whether or not he's a
good Henry Cavill is a good Superman or
not so let us know in the comments if
you've good Superman to be a bad
Superman is it in the middle like me I
don't know one thing I will say before
we go he looks good as Superman I feel
like he has the potential to be the
Superman that we want but it's just not
there I don't think Henry Cavill himself
has been given good enough material to
really shine a few ringgit you see the
pictures of him when he goes to dislike
charities and things with children and
he see him in that costume
brainy's iris he's with children he has
that smile on his face and I even gave
him a spit curl and like that Superman
he looks like Superman and that's why
I'm hoping they're like if Henry Cavill
can do that out of right you do I mean I
kind of like me and I'm hoping now that
they seem to be wanting to
course-correct because everyone was like
BBS was so dark and they're like okay
Justice League is going to be happy guys
like me we promise we only have like I'm
one really worth it after we found out
about how much you need a Batman but
it's going to be fun that maybe we're
going to get more of that guy a Superman
okay so I think yes I think we'll see I
think it's a wait and see decimals big
wait wait personality okay so rise again
oh at all yeah don't write at equalities
happiness we'll just have to wait and
see yeah all right guys
Porter where can people find you on
social medias facebook.com slash awesome
Porter Twitter pork chop zero two eight
nine great and fake where can people
find you in social media if they want to
come either disgust I'm on Twitter at AJ
cling because I didn't want to put the
budget link of the photos cocky so this
others in the world's like that I'm odd
you can find me at Adjei clang LAN GE if
I spell my last name i'm also on
instagram somewhere i don't have to find
me you don't even remember stuff but
yeah it's what our twitter is usually
the best way to get home man so awesome
great and you can find me on twitter at
Heather roof or on this de gram at a
truth and don't forget to like the
Facebook page facebook.com slash awesome
comics show and we'll definitely
continue the discussion with you guys
there but until next time we'll see you
on the next page
[Music]
[Applause]